hello there have you played the new
imposter mode in fortnite well in
addition to being a great game mode
there are countless secrets and
references to find and by countless i
mean 36 some are inconsequential and
others may be foreshadowing the future
so if you'd kindly sit your butt down
for 10 minutes and slap code adamarro in
the store let's do this
[Music]
okay let's start small and work up to
the big stuff before starting a pc based
task in-game a screensaver will be
running a bouncing i o symbol if you're
old enough to remember dvds you'll
recognize this at school we used to
watch these for hours in the hopes of
seeing the symbol hit the corner
perfectly and it turns out we weren't
alone every single teenager in the
entire world did this and a few adults
too
and now it's in fortnite and yes it does
hit the corner very satisfying okay back
to the start of the game mode did this
pre-game lobby look familiar to you it
turns out this is a repurposed set of
assets from the unvaulting live event
back in may 2019 more than two years ago
the colour scheme has been updated but
it's the same flaw we walked on when we
unvolted the drum gun this easter egg
has a second part speaking of that live
event at the rear of the armory is a
vaulting panel which has a gun you may
not have seen before fortnite og's will
remember this as the zapatron a save the
world weapon which accidentally found
its way into br for a few hours french
streamer ionix was the first to record a
clip which has been shared countless
times soon after the zapatron was
removed and returned to the vault and
now we know where it's been all this
time safely locked away when will it be
set free save the world gets a second
nod in the weapon room over by this wall
of weapons everything here is accounted
for but one of these is not like the
others you may be asking yourself what
it is this my friends is the zap zap an
alien weapon which uses three power
cells per shot as we don't use energy
cells in battle royale it's unlikely
this gun will be the same if it does
come to br but if fortnite want to
introduce some more sci-fi weapons to
the island season seven is the perfect
time
on to jonesy's room this place is great
i can safely say jonesy is a bachelor or
a man-child take a look around in here
and you'll see so many references to the
history of fortnite it'll blow your mind
jones's wardrobe shows us a collection
of his alter egos over the years this is
most likely how he's re-entering the
loop without being noticed he simply
dresses up like a former snapshot but
one thing in here teaches us so much
more take a look at jones's wardrobe a
suit for every day of the week but one
suit is missing though we now know the
exact day jonesy was last here it was a
chose day mate i did a little research
and found that the device event happened
on monday the 15th of june 2020 so this
doesn't completely marry up perfectly
but in australia and the southern
hemisphere the event did happen on a
tuesday anyway jones's suit wasn't
looking too good by the end elsewhere in
this room i'm sure you've noticed the
mini games referencing dance dance
revolution and the original street
fighter at the arcade cabinet we'll take
a look see here and you'll see a host of
nods to the fortnite world the alien
rifle the merman statue and the green
lantern mask have previously been on the
island already remember where
it was the rig midas chambers had these
items in and also the venturion skin
which was changed to the cyclo skin
before the event
it looks like agent jones snuck into
here took a few midas mementos before
going back to his desk and watching the
event another season two item is below
it from the grotto the sword which sat
in brutus's room it was also the most
click-baited sword in youtuber
thumbnails for about a week back when
deadpool arrived
now it belongs to jones this next
cabinet took me on a six hour research
deep dive on the web all because of this
box with multiple warnings not to open i
mean there are four warnings here
identifying the shape was tough but i
can confirm this shape of cube with
triangular edges is known as pandora's
cube the term pandora's box typically
refers to something that is best left
alone because it will cause problems if
opened and judging by those warnings
this theory lines up well the story of
pandora's box is a legend used by
ancient greeks to explain human weakness
and lack of control her curiosity
eventually got the better of her like it
is with me right now and long story
short inside was pure suffering
lovely that one that wasn't the end of
my research though but let's put a pin
in this but it gets good i promise you
let's crack on there is something in
this room i'm unable to decipher if
you'd be so kind to help me out on the
way into the room on the right-hand wall
are many images of agent jones but the
quality is too low to get any details
some sort of space travel to an alien
planet the color scheme matches up with
the current alien invasion but the map
that map is new also who is he hugging
here i'll be honest not knowing he's
killing me
next onto loop control the design of
this room is taken from the marvel world
and the x-men it's cerebro this is a
place professor x would go to locate and
communicate with any mutant on earth it
began as an epcot looking golf ball
before it was taken underground and
hidden from prying eyes just like loop
control in fortnite oh and while we're
here stick around and see what happens
when the imposters break it spam bots
fill the room with this kind of stuff
one of these took my eye as it looks
like a character model mesh i'm
completely hopeless at identifying skins
but luckily my discord fam is cracked
and they told me this was summit striker
a completely random easter egg to put in
but maybe this skin has more importance
than we know it was a starter pack
wasn't it i'm sure you've found jonesy's
office in-game and matched it up with
the version from the trailers it looks
pretty good doesn't it did you also
notice that sloane's office is here too
we can't go in but it's a great nod to
the character all the same while
something happens in these rooms keep an
eye on the clock and you'll notice that
the hands flip around when an imposter
sabotages this could be a nod to the
clock during the live event of the
device all those months ago many people
reported that the clock timer changed
dramatically each time the loop was
affected this would tie into the law or
maybe it's just there because it's just
there sometimes the simplest answers are
the right ones
okay on to the science lab what a great
room this is we have a tiny version of
kevin the cube which we can feed our
trash it's difficult to know if this is
the og cube a new version or maybe a
cutting from the one that exploded
looking elsewhere in the room we can see
the mecca team leaders helm being
analyzed after her visit to another
dimension but here's something i'm
confused by on the opposite side of the
room there is another item analyzer but
someone has removed it
it may be nothing but epic wouldn't go
so far to make this room so detailed and
forget to put something here so keep an
eye on this spot just next to the other
marvel easter egg captain america's
shield on to the other side of the room
on the right hand side is a fragment of
the meteor if you weren't around in
chapter one you may not know the
importance of this thing this is how the
seven got onto our island either the
visitor or the foundation all we know
for certain is that the seven are
considered the enemy of the io and now
we see they are analyzing their mode of
transport and then we have the infinity
blade the sword which broke the game
back in season seven of chapter one this
actually has law which could relate to
the story especially now it's in the
same room as the cube let's break some
law down the infinity blade is a weapon
so powerful it can kill one of the
deathless a breed of warriors in the
infinity blade world who cannot be
killed here's where things get funky one
of the seals of the deathless used is
guarded via a language called pangean
which looks like this notice anything
about it it's the same runes as on the
cube and wait there's more remember the
pandora cube in jones's room well that
sigil the marking on that cube is in
fact another seal from infinity blade
that's three references to infinity
blade including the infinity blade this
could all be coincidence and reuse of
asset or now the infinity blade series
is over this could be a way to bring
that world into fortnite maybe we should
open that box after all
okay let's lighten the mood did you know
that officially epic games agrees with
me that if you put pineapple on your
pizza you are a psycho it's fact i
expect anyone who's willing to add
pineapple to a pizza to own up in the
comments and renounce all sins oh on one
of the monitors you can find this image
these are from when everyone expected
tilted towers to be eradicated in
chapter one we were completely wrong but
the runes and the theory matched up
really well and now it's an easter egg
oh stand around long enough and look
into the sea and you will spot a shark a
good looking fellow too and that brings
me to the csi room crime scene
investigation down here is a treasure
trove of theories and law
first that shark on the whiteboard
you'll see a shark with a laser on its
head which became the laser trump glider
in game this is actually an easter egg
to an easter egg which is a nod to
austin powers and dr evil's desire to
own well i'll i'll let him say himself
and that is to have sharks with freaking
laser beams attached to their heads the
shark project seems to be named bruce
after the shark from finding nemo who is
the basis for the fortnite design hello
and things get a little more strange
because the team are planning on turbo
charging sharks with a rocket propeller
i'm down for that and a guy named
harrison needs to be reminded of this do
not feed the sharks no matter what they
tell you whether this is a nod to an
employee at epic or a new character to
be aware of the advice is important to
every single one of us on the other side
of the room is a crazy detailed theory
board which is extremely low resolution
first we have io attempting to uncover
the leader of the seven the thing is
almost all of these images here are from
our real world discussions on reddit and
twitter asking about the seven epic
literally used our own images to show
how obsessed we are with finding answers
on here we see shots of previous events
and members of the seven but wait who's
that
the prisoner
back in chapter one season seven this
chap was frozen by the ice king but
slowly thawed out over the season he
eventually regained his flame based
powers and suddenly a volcano appeared
from that day we didn't see him again
this is the first reference to the
prisoner in years
but wait there's more go back up to
jones's bedroom and check who lives next
door
someone very flammable occupies the next
room there are many fiery characters in
fortnite but i think this is what
happened to the prisoner he's inside
this room or it's the human torch and
finally i shall leave you with a
question back in the csi room it's
possible to see a map of chapter two
with three strings attached as a clue
all the strings begin at steamy stacks
and end at the places we currently call
coral castle retail row and the former
central island whatever this means the
io are linking it to the seven i have no
theories here can you understand this
and can you let me know please thank you
very much so there we have it 36 secrets
easter eggs and references in as quick a
fashion as i could i'm adam you're
awesome and thank you to those people
who use my code this week i'll be back
in my twitter dms tomorrow to thank you
personally see ya
[Music]